the Joe Rogan experience one of those
morning shows [ __ ] off like the way
we're talking about be like the best
morning show so much green had a great
great with our memory now back when he
was like I'd like access yeah he's
trying to promote as public access oh
yeah I'm a Tom Green show and he just
took over he did some crazy eyes in the
face yeah that's amazing like him and
then that other dude Jamie Kennedy they
did their best [ __ ] where they were like
pranking people chuck us and then they
just stopped yeah man but Tom's blew up
so crazy so crazy someone talking
resolved I couldn't it was stuff I
couldn't even believe I'm Green did
Oprah Wow oh yes Oprah was like we're
gonna it was such a phenomenal what was
going on show was so big he milked it by
with his mouth yeah but he put [ __ ]
mobile on his dad my parents and then
hid in the bushes yeah he didn't just
like let me [ __ ] this man of people like
my mommy and daddy
people forget did people forget Tom
Green what happened to before no no he's
small cancer had to take a break came
back and try to do like a more serious
show with Humperdinck what's this guy's
name but what's his people forgot how
big it used to be oh one of the man what
he did was he did what we're all doing
way before any of us but was one band
was too expensive he you did I did it
his house it was part of the inspiration
for me doing one yeah and his yes I even
talked to his company they were based in
Denver I was in Denver doing the comedy
works and I talked to the company that
was doing it for him and I was seriously
considering doing something like that
but the problem was that it like the man
was crazy expensive he had cables
running from the desk all the way
through his living room into a server
room he had a server room and it was
crazy I know how much money is involved
in this he's like a fuckload of money
and he was like I have to have all these
people running it - that was Tom Green's
green and he so what essentially was was
he decided to try to do a talk show host
I remember that Joe Rogan the [ __ ]
long-sleeve under the short sleeve
with the torn jeans you were like I'm
not coming to Hollywood giving up if he
that was all based on one come once
which he had in his house I know he just
go on and flip a switch and the show
went on in one life so me and red band
looked at it and we're like well how
much is involved in this like what do we
have to do to do something like this and
then you know eventually it just led to
with that and ku Mia Anthony ku Mia was
that was a big bang yeah he had that
live from the compound in his basement
and then the way that Opie and Anthony
ran their show was an inspiration to
because it was just a hangout and it was
my favorite show to listen to yeah cuz
just a bunch of guys hanging out talking
I was like that's like that's what I
want to do